The SCP Foundation specializes in tracking
down and containing anomalies that are difficult
to find, and that often will do anything they
can to avoid being found.
One anomaly in particular hates being seen
more than anything, and will punish anyone
who looks at its face with a horrific fate.
SCP-096 is a mysterious creature, not only
because it destroys anyone who sees what it
truly looks like.
No one is entirely certain where it came from,
what exactly it is, or why it reacts so violently
to being perceived.
There are, however, several theories as to
the Shy Guy's origin, and none of them are
particularly cheerful.
Some suggest an experiment gone wrong, others
believe it to be the last remaining member
of an unknown species of mountain-dwelling
humanoids.
But one theory about SCP-096's origin stands
out as particularly tragic in nature.
In this story, SCP-096 was not always a long-limbed,
pale beast cowering in the corner and hiding
its face from the world.
It was once an ordinary man, like anyone you
might pass on the street.
He was someone's son, someone's friend, a
person with hopes, dreams, and passions.
A human being who, through anomalous circumstances
beyond his control, was made into a monster.
Many years ago, there was a mountaineer named
Jack.
All his adult life, he had been obsessed with
reaching higher and higher peaks, climbing
every mountain he could in order to test his
limits, pit himself against the power of nature,
and bask in the sweet reward that was the
view from the top.
It began as a sport, a way to build up strength
while taking in incredible natural beauty,
but over time as he conquered increasingly
difficult challenges, it became an obsession.
Like every obsession eventually does, climbing
mountains began to take over his life, driving
everything else away.
He struggled to hold down a job, his marriage
fell apart, and his relationships to his friends
and family became increasingly distant and
strained.
Still, he couldn't bring himself to care much.
He spent his time alone in the wilderness,
or every so often embarking on trips with
other mountaineers.
Whether he was going at it solo or working
with others, he was living for the climb.
Over the years, he took on Cerro Torre in
Argentina, The Eiger in Switzerland, and Denali
in Alaska.
He especially enjoyed climbing in extreme
cold, braving the ice and snow as he embarked
on his climbs.
The few fellow mountaineers he kept up with
gave him the nickname "Jack Frost."
After years of refining his craft, building
his strength, he set his sights on the highest
mountain in the world, his personal white
whale: Mt.
Everest itself.
It was one of the deadliest climbs in the
world, with its staggering height, storms,
and frozen graveyard of fallen climbers dotting
the snowy surface.
But he was determined.
He would not join the ranks of the fallen,
but instead, be one of the victorious that
reached the top of Everest and came back down
in one piece.
He could feel it in his bones.
Jack arrived in Nepal with a pack full of
climbing equipment, the best boots money could
buy, and layers upon layers of clothing to
keep himself warm on the journey to the summit.
He lowered his goggles over his eyes, summoned
his courage, and prepared for the incredibly
difficult climb.
The cold seeped into his core, the winds nipped
at his face, numbing his nose and leeching
through his gloves and boots as he went, but
Jack pressed on.
He welcomed the sensation, the bite of it.
It was a reminder that he was still here,
that he was still alive.
As long as he could feel the pain, he knew
he was alright.
He knew that it was when the cold faded away,
turned to paradoxical feelings of warmth and
sleepiness, that a mountaineer was truly in
trouble.
As he navigated the harsh mountain landscape,
Jack occasionally let his eyes drift off course,
taking in the sights around him.
He could see shocks of blue, green, and red,
the distinct bright colors of boots, jackets,
and hats belonging to the fallen climbers
that came before him.
Those who collapsed from exhaustion, who gave
in to altitude sickness or succumbed to the
cold.
"Memento Mori."
He said softly to himself.
These frozen bodies represented that ever-present
reminder of mortality, of death lurking just
out of sight.
It would not come for him though.
Not today, not on this journey.
He wouldn't let it.
The hours blurred together within the crunch
of the ice beneath his boots, the dig of climbing
hooks into the earth, the tug of his trusty
ropes as he ascended ever higher.
Jack came to a stop.
There was no next step to take, nowhere higher
that he could go.
He had reached the summit.
The white whale was captured, and Everest
was his.
For the very first time, he was truly on top
of the world.
Now that he had made it to the highest point,
there was the all-important task of climbing
back down.
At this altitude, he was still in the "death
zone," the place where human acclimatization
was impossible.
This was the tricky part, the point at which
even the most experienced of climbers might
get lost in the euphoria of the achievement
might let their attention slip.
Any mistake during his descent, any misstep,
could be the thing that cost him his life.
There was no room for error and no time to
waste.
Just as Jack prepared to make his descent,
he saw a figure pulling itself over the ridge.
From a distance, it looked like a fellow climber.
He noted the curious lack of equipment, and
the way the person seemed to be making their
way up the mountain with nothing but their
hands, but perhaps they had lost their pack
or left it behind for some reason.
The figure was dressed in all white from their
hood to their boots, with a large pair of
black mountain goggles covering what little
of their face wasn't concealed by the hood.
Uncertain if the figure was in need of assistance,
and surprised to see another soul on the mountain
with him, Jack waved at the figure.
"Everything okay?"
He called.
There was no response, but the figure turned
to look at him.
At least, he thought it was looking at him.
He couldn't see its eyes through the goggles,
but he felt the distinct sensation of it locking
its gaze with his, just the same.
As soon as the figure turned to look at him,
Jack began to feel strange.
The pain, the sharp sensation of the cold
that he relied on to ground himself and remember
he was really here, began to blur around the
edges.
The feeling softened, melting away along with
the ache in his muscles, the bleariness in
his eyes, the dry mouth that had nagged at
him for hours.
He felt unbalanced, unmoored, a ship with
no anchor.
He couldn't explain why, but the sudden relief
from the cold made his chest tighten with
primal terror.
He did not feel like one man encountering
another on the mountain.
He felt the way he had years ago when he came
face to face with a mountain lion, staring
down a predator and remembering all of a sudden
that humans do not naturally sit at the top
of the food chain.
This figure, this thing...it was no man.
It was no person.
Jack prepared to continue his descent, to
get away from the strange intruder as quickly
as possible, but his feet would not obey him.
His eyes could not break contact with the
figure in white that was slowly beginning
to advance toward him, one slow step at a
time.
It was in no hurry.
It knew he was not going anywhere any time
soon.
He trembled as the figure drew closer, its
inscrutable face hidden beneath its hood and
behind its goggles.
He wished he could see its face, but dreaded
learning what secrets it was hiding.
If only he could just unstick his feet from
the earth, break free of this spell that had
fallen over him, he could escape.
But no matter how his muscles strained, how
he gritted his teeth with effort, he couldn't
get away.
As the entity came closer, the cold snapped
back into his body- but something was different.
It was heightened, like every icy breeze and
freezing wind layered on top of itself, hardening
his muscles to rock, crystallizing the very
blood in his veins.
He felt as if his fingers, if he tried to
wriggle them, would snap off and fall to the
ground.
His eyes thrummed in their sockets, his lungs
struggling to hold onto each breath as the
cold constricted its fist around his chest.
He opened his mouth to speak but his voice
died in his throat, coming out in a weak whisper
of air.
Now, the thing was close enough to touch him,
and whatever force had been holding him still
and upright released him.
It was as if he were a marionette suspended
in the air, and the puppeteer released his
strings all at once.
He crumpled to the snow-covered ground in
a heap, his cheek pressed into the earth,
his eyes trained helplessly on the still-advancing
figure.
His lips formed the word "please..." though
he could not tell exactly what he was begging
for.
His life?
His freedom?
A painless death?
He struggled to push himself to his feet,
but all the strength had gone out of his limbs.
He could barely lift his arm, let alone handle
the weight of his whole body.
The thing shaped like a man was right above
him, glowering down through those opaque goggles.
He still could not see its eyes, but somehow
he could feel the way it was looking at him.
Hatred was radiating off of it, disdain and
pure, unadulterated malice.
Then, it tilted its head to the side thoughtfully,
and Jack's mind was overwhelmed with images.
He felt the phantom sensation of sunlight
on his skin, and springy green grass beneath
his bare feet.
He could see, clear as day in his mind's eye,
a forest clearing in the middle of summer,
dewdrops sparkling on the petals of wildflowers
blowing in a gentle, sweet breeze.
Then, he felt sand between his toes, smelled
the sea breeze, felt the comfort and contentment
of a nap on the beach.
It was not offering these things to him, but
something like them...something like peace.
It was offering him...a gift.
But he didn't want it.
He couldn't take it.
He was Jack Frost, dammit, he thrived in the
cold, the hardship.
He didn't want some warm, sleepy fade out
of existence.
If he went out, it would be on his terms,
doing the thing he had dedicated his life
to.
If he were going to lose his life, he wouldn't
roll over and just give it up.
It would need to be pried from his frozen
hands.
With every last bit of strength, he twisted
his head away from the entity's gaze, covering
his face with his hands.
It grabbed at him, shaking his shoulders,
trying to force him to uncover his face and
meet its gaze once more, but he didn't budge.
He wouldn't.
He couldn't.
Then, he felt the energy shift as it realized
he had refused the gift, that he would not
welcome the paradoxical feelings of heat and
security and slip away as it was asking him
to.
But it was not a victory.
He swore he could hear a voice in his mind
say, "Very well...you wish to be part of the
mountain?
I will make it so."
The world went white as Jack's eyes rolled
back in his head, his spine curving back until
it snapped.
His jaw cracked and distended, his arms and
legs stretched out long and twisted, his body
contorted at unnatural angles as the entity
began to rearrange his very being.
As the agony ripped through him, snapping
his bones and tearing his muscles, Jack kept
his face cradled in his hands.
He remained in that position even as he cried
his voice hoarse, as the pure fear and pain
overwhelmed his senses, until he forgot his
own name, forget he was ever a man at all.
When Jack was no more, when something else
sat there in his place, pale and shivering,
body wracked with sobs, the King of the Mountain
turned and left him there, alone with his
misery.
Still, he would not uncover his face.
He would not let himself be vulnerable, would
not look up.
Days later, a group of mountaineers reached
the summit of Everest and spotted a hairless
figure crouched in the snow, weeping softly.
"Are you alright?"
One of them asked.
The figure lifted its head slowly, and locked
eyes with the strangers.
Its eyes widened in horror, its mouth stretched
impossibly wide in a wordless scream of rage
and hurt, and, with nothing human left in
its mind or heart, SCP-096 took its very first
victim.
Now go check out “SCP-096 Shy Guy ESCAPE
- Incident 096-1-A Containment Breach” and
“How Are Bodies Actually Frozen on Mount
Everest?
- SCP-1529 - King of the Mountain” for more
on the players in today’s harrowing video!